tintin c'est non non c'est quoi la
question j'ai pas compris
[Applaudissements]
alors attention là mais j'ai pas compris
j'ai pas entendu truc j'ai pas entendu
plus fort j'ai pas entendu je suis
souvent allé on repasse le masi toile
est si particulière et vas-y regarder
dans une bd bande dessinée si des rg
quel duo de garnements d'un carrousel
roussel et bien fait nos petits
lancement du journal du hard avec un
titre que vous voulez le journal du a
maintenant passé c'est gentil merci pour
votre fidélité et alors tout de suite un
extrait de ce nouveau film et cette
nouvelle production franco hollandaise
qui s'appelle panique dos libre et
pourquoi il n'y a pas de ballons dans
questions pour un champion
parce que julien lepers savoir je
t'expliquerai vous pouvez acheter ma
voiture une voiture allemande
on n'en dira pas plus d'accord j'ai fait
mettre une voiture allemande qui a un
nom et d'espagnol 3 d'être haut parleurs
poussé à haut-parleurs mais qui ne se
voit pas haut-parleurs extérieur ce qui
fait que que quand une mamie qui met un
temps fou à traverser
c est ce que c'est possible de traverser
plus vite non non mais c'est pas vrai
youtube par le sac l'écart avec les
poireaux c'est possible de traverser
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]